hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to another video today
we're going to be talking all about
unreal engine 4
and visual assist a match made in heaven
so i know that on this channel we
haven't really talked about
large projects very often unreal engine
4 being a great example of a
very large sequel project and on the
other hand i have mentioned
just how much i love visual assist and
how i've been using it for like
literally 90
of my siblings lost development that
i've done in my whole life i've also
made a video showing my favorite
features of visual assist and so i
thought for
this video i would partner with visual
assist to show you guys some of the
amazing unreal engine 4 specific
features that visual assist actually has
as well as how visual assist can
actually help you deal with
really large projects now i want to
start off by saying that if you are
writing c
plus code inside visual studio
visual assist is an absolute must-have
as far as i'm concerned
yes it is true the visual studio has of
course improved throughout the years but
in my experience it's still not just
up to the level of features the visual
assist actually provides you with
and if you're dealing with large
solutions like we're going to be looking
at today
it can actually offer some serious
benefits the first real thing that i
want to mention
is just performance when you're dealing
with a large code base things can get
extremely slow i find myself fighting
the tools i'm actually working with
constantly i mean back when i worked at
ea on frostbite
that was a fantastic example that
solution is absolutely massive
and there were just so many visual
studio features that i found that i had
to disable
because it was just taking too long to
just like display syntax highlighting
or open a file stuff like that one of
the biggest culprits of this something
called intellisense intellisense is
something that's built into visual
studio that basically
passes all the code to figure out things
like autocomplete
you know little squiggly errors that
come up as well as syntax highlighting
which of course is very
important now anyone that has worked on
a giant solution in visual studio knows
that one of the first things you want to
do
is just disable intellisense because if
you leave that bad boy on
it's not it's not going to be a good
time however when you disable
intellisense you lose so much
but that's where visual assist can come
in and really make life easier for you
because not only does visual assist
actually have their own parsing and
syntax highlighting and all of that
an amazing engine that deals with all
that stuff it's also
better than the default visual studio
one they have this thing called enhanced
syntax highlighting which just makes
everything look really pretty
and it it can actually pass symbols a
lot deeper than what visual studio can
do
natively so for something like unreal
engine 4 i mean whether you're actually
working on the code base
or an actual game built using unreal
engine 4 we'll get into that a little
bit later
but i for one i'm building my own game
engine called hazel so
it's pretty it's pretty common that i
will go through other engines especially
something like
unreal unreligion 4 whose source code is
freely accessible
and actually see how they're doing
things and just see the general
architecture of their engine
when i'm going through all of their
engine code i want to be able to do that
efficiently and quickly obviously i
don't want visual studio just slowing
everything down
so one of the ways that i do that is i
disable intellisense for the unreal
engine 4 solution and i just use
visual assist and to be honest i i don't
even miss intellisense whatsoever
i mean i remember working back on
frostbite and literally one of the first
things
in the documentation once you check out
that engine and you finally have it on
your computer like
a day or two later it literally says
disable intellisense
like this is such a big problem for all
of these large solutions and i just
i wouldn't dream of trying to go through
something like that without visual
assist now for anyone who has actually
gone through
unreal engine 4 source code you'll note
that there are so
many language extensions and various
macros that they actually use because
they have their
own passes as well which reflect things
in the editor and all of that kind of
fun stuff and in fact it doesn't you
don't even have to look through unreal
engine 4's source code
this is also something you'll encounter
all the time if you're actually just
trying to build a game
using unreal engine and if you're
specifically writing like scripts in c
plus plus they basically have these like
macros starting with u so like u class u
function that kind of stuff which their
own tools will then later pass
now because of these extra language
extensions visual studio and
its parser tends to get extremely
confused specifically the formatter
as well and it starts to misalign things
all the time
i personally hate that but that's one of
the benefits of using a tool that's
actually aware of all of these language
extensions and extra syntax
like visual assist because it's been
developed specifically with unreal
engine 4 in mind i mean it
literally has an unreal engine 4 mode
that you can enable
it actually fixes all of that and whilst
fixing things like
indentation and tabs which visual assist
does is it i mean it's really annoying
but it's not the end of the world
visual assist actually understands the
structure of unreal engine
a lot more than just indentation and
taps for example
when you're trying to navigate through
certain new functions which may have
validation enabled
this kind of underscore implementation
underscore validate methods since visual
assist is aware of that when you press
alt g for example to actually go to a
particular function definition
it pops up for you because it knows what
that is
but of course the coolest thing is that
because visual assists
like parsing engine is actually aware of
all this fancy unreal engine 4 stuff it
means that all of visual assist tools
actually work with these things so if
you're trying to refactor something if
you're trying to implement a virtual
function
things like autocomplete they they work
something as simple as properly parsing
all of this unreal engine 4 code and i'm
of course i'm not just talking about
the engine source code i'm talking about
the actual game that you're making in
unreal engine 4
all of that code that uses unreal engine
4's features being able to actually
parse all of that code
properly to provide you with a better
development experience is something that
visual assist does
very well whereas intellisense gets
confused a lot of time and actually
underlines certain things as errors when
they're not
because it has no idea what's going on
so if you're working on a project with
unreal engine 4 or you're actually
extending the source code maybe or
browsing the engine source code
i highly recommend you take a look at
visual assist i'll leave a link in the
description below to both an article
that covers some of the other features
that visual assist offers for unreal
engine 4
which i didn't get to in this video as
well as a link to visual assist itself
along with a 30-day free trial that you
can check out
and as always i highly recommend that
you guys check out visual assist even if
you're not working with unreal engine 4
c plus in visual studio needs visual
assist that's been my belief for like
over five years
and it's definitely the first thing i
install when i install visual studio
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and that it was helpful to you
definitely let me know if you do try
this out and if you have been using
visual assist with unreal engine and how
you've been finding it
don't forget to hit the like button of
course if you did enjoy the video and i
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]